こんにちは、クリスと申します。
during our reserate, our website.
the
Good afternoon. My name is Chris
and my honor to be here to give a special talk today at the DrupalCamp Iwakuni.
Our University OIST
build the Drupal 7 site in 2011,
which was the first year of its release.
Drupal 7 had the longest lifespan among all the versions, and brought significant changes
to this platform.
One of these change was the integration of CCK as the content type entity field.
He wrote
views to the core. Additionally, image cache was transformed into that image style
last year
we underwent a two-year journey to rebuild and monitor the website, using Drupal
in the first part of the talk I will discuss the development and the project management process whims through during the website revealed
in the second part of my talk
will delve that deeper into the challenges we faced when localizing the website
for our bilingual English and Japanese audiences.
I will share the issue we encountered beyond just translation, and how we address them to provide the best experience to our users.
First.
a little bit about myself.
I'm. A Duba developer with 14 years of experience in drupal development.
I have extensive experience in web design and development in traditional Chinese, Japanese, and English.
I'm. Also a member of the Drupal community, and a former group leader in Taiwan
outside of Jubal. I'm. Also interested in coffee, Germany, and cats, and welcome any conversation about those topics as well.
Before jumping to the topic.
Please note that any mention of the vendor or products in this talk.
not
endorsement.
Our old Drupal 7 side served as well. Bring in over 30
million visits, and deliver 37,000 pieces of mountain.
In the last 3 years we doubled our monthly visit
the website, share our accomplishment with the world, such as when we need to have a new lab building were completed
when we received high impact rankings in nature, and when our faculty member won the Nobel Prize recently.
the website continuously to celebrate the success.
however, we continue to strive for innovation and shape the future of research in Japan.
In order to reach
this goes.
we have to set the new objectives and needed a new website that could deliver our outcome in a more effective and flexible way
in 2,020
OISTer
strategic plan, and begin to
emphasize the 3 Peter of activities, research, education, and innovation.
It is also our responsibility to raise the awareness of STEM education, contribute to Okinawa and conduct outreach activities in the Japanese society.
Throughout the entire project. We kept these 3 main Peters in my
and made sure that all the website aligned with the organization
strategics
from a technical perspective. Our goal was to improve the accountant management. Experience for editors.
Drupal and I allow us to use the media library to manage assets
and change the Node translation, method to field translation
in relation to Drupal. We also implement a design system to maintain the consistency in user experience and enable editors to easily reuse weptic component when creating content.
The website project was divided into 3 main faces.
We conducted a comprehensive user research with a vendor in December, 2020 to gain better understanding of the stakeholders, both internal and external users.
The study helped us identify how users perceive us.
and how we can improve the website Information architecture
In the second phase we hire another vendor to migrate the content and build a new website. Using Triple 9.
The vendor completed the development. The
our web team took over the content.
We convert it and recreate the content and trend the content owner on how to use the new website.
Our developer and I also work on updating and resolving any additional issues.
Last December, 2 years after we begin the project, we successfully relaunch the website.
It has been well received by the OIST community.
Let's take a quick tour of the site. Now
we redefine the color scheme and use the new web component throughout the site.
The Mega menu provide the user with a better navigation map.
Our media editor can mainly select the related content, or let the system choose a related content for them.
We integrate the flicker into the site
to allow us to preview our photo albums
for different campaign or special committees.
We have a microsi feature
which allows them to manage their own content and display their own logo.
Finally, we have also created a style guide to showcase the components
we design for the website.
Now this moved on to the technical aspect of our project.
I would like to provide a high-level overview of the migration process. And how we manage the Development project.
Migration was the first and the most important factor in our project.
Important content and assets need to be migrated.
It wasn't just about migrating the content node. We also had to migrate files and image that were not managing the Cms.
In 2,007.
There was no media library, so we used the video and photo content type to contain assets and later use the short code to reference them in the content body.
This means we had to migrate all 3,000 content notes and over 6,000 media assets. First.
then convert all the inline circle into the new media embedded format.
In the past
Content editors were able to use the I and C to upload the files and image to the server directly
during the migration we converted over 1,500 in life, ourselves into media types.
including images, documents, and embedded videos. This not only ensure that all the files in the managed system, but also
makes the system more secure.
In total, we migrate more than 10,000 content, and assets via the drupal migrate Api script.
The migrate profile was kept in use in the project to provide mockup data for testing purpose
during each feature development. Our local environment and class Ci environment builds the site with the mockup data. Every time.
This allows us to run the unit test repeatedly
and make our deployment more robust and reliable.
Migration was critical to the project.
and require a lot of efforts to review, content, and validate the results by us worth it.
play the crucial role in the project. Success
beyond migration.
There were 3 keys that make the project success.
We made sure to keep our team and the Supervisor informed of our progress.
OIST is a large organization, with many decision making channel. So when necessary, we made a stakeholder directly, and then find someone who could support and communicate
to the right channel.
We use a tool effectively to manage project tasks and assist with the communication.
There is no best tool that we find the right to that. All team members were willing to use
to reduce repetitive tasks and risks. The
we rely on test and automation process as much as possible.
All these factors work together to make their project a success
during the first stage of the project. When we walk with the vendor
they use the Github and its project tool to manage the tasks.
This allowed their developer and us to communicate freely
rather than only through the project manager.
This accelerate development made the work transparent and increase the Meteor Trust.
After the project was delivered. We introduced Surecott to manage both development and content creation tasks on the same platform
with Shortcut. We were able to integrate Github to track the status of the Pr. And sinking Development task status.
Many of us already familiar with Github and their project managed tool have been more mature and user-friendly. Now.
showcart is a task management system that can easily manage both development and editing tasks.
Given that the task of development and editing require different workflow.
we can create different workflow in shortcut for them.
and then bring them into the same epic or iteration easily.
This is very helpful for a team with multiple functions.
In shortcut. We can quickly think the status of death tasks with Github.
even though there are 2 separate platform, we can walk between them simulously.
We are a 2 developer development team and need to focus on tasks and resolving issues.
The Csd Process act as a third developer.
checking the code standard and deploying the code for us.
This allow our developer to quickly move on to the next task. After committing the code to the online development environment.
Once the commit passed the C IC. Workflow.
We can then focus on reviewing the logic of the code in pull request.
then ask the Ci CD to deploy it to the production site
with all the tools, script, and continuous communication.
we were able to complete the project smoothly.
Of course, the television team member is.
were the core of the project's success.
OIST is a unique graduate university in Japan, with over 50% of our
members being international, including employees and students.
Our cell signal unit is a diverse example
with the leading faculty. Federal researchers and students from different countries.
As a result.
English and Japanese are equally important at
and most of the content on our website is translated into both languages
During the project we deal with many translations, issues, and in the second part of this talk.
I'd like to focus on a few of them, particularly for our Japanese and Apex region attendees today.
Drupal has well-defined translation system in core
depends on your experience and role.
There are always ways for you to make translations
as a iboder.
We can translate nodes with a field translation in a boat.
Also, we can translate many strings that appears in the user interface.
As a simmer we use tweak to Marx translatable sentence with a variable in it.
As a developer.
we can mark the translatable string with the T function.
It is also capable to use dynamic variable in the sentence.
However, there might be a chance that we need a translation context
because a word could be verb or known, or has more than one meaning.
For example.
contact.
It will be translated into 2 different words in Japanese
as the action conductor
as a section label in Nakosaki.
There are more details about localizing user experience in my talk at the latest triple-comp.
If you are interested in working on bilingual site more often it will be helpful for you. But today I want to focus on the issues specific to the project and related to the Japanese languages.
One issue to consider is the date format
in Japan
as well as in to one.
We typically use a format that starts with the year followed by the months and day.
In the other country we often see this state format.
which can be interpreted
as either September twelfth or December ninth, depending on the country. For example, most European countries read it as December ninth, while the United States.
with it as September the twelfth.
Given the diversity of our University member.
we have to find a common way to ensure our understanding of information is consistent.
Therefore we use the Iso format in English ui, as it is the same order
format for the Japanese Ui.
Another issue to consider is typing in Japanese, Chinese, or Korean, often referred to as Cjk languages.
Type. Enrollment alphabet on a keyboard is relatively easy. But how are words hyped in Cjk languages?
Here are some paragraph in Cj. About what to do. If you receive the positive COVID-19 notification from the Health Center.
you can see
that in C. J. Care languages
the sentence rarely have spaces
to index the content to the database and make it easy to search.
Sometimes we need extra treatment.
So how do we type? What's this Cjk keyboard looks like
From the left to right
we see 2 traditional Chinese keyboards.
and there are 2 Korean keyboards, layout, and 2 Japanese layout, one in mobile, and the other one is a compact keyboard with the 50
essential science correctors
For those who you don't understand the language.
They may look like a possible right
when typing the words. The keystrokes vary
for the work computer.
we can also tell. It is different in traditional Chinese used in Taiwan or simplified Chinese in China
when typing Cdk text. A word is completed only when all the segment is typed.
Unlike typing English.
there might be possible worry combination before finish the typing
in this clip
it shows that in pulling
Japanese kanji requires typing one to 4 or even more the mendic elements.
Additionally.
there are different words in Kanji, which have the same pronunciation.
This can be to an issue in the search
box
where the search is triggered too early before the actual keyword is completed
which can be annoying for the users.
The issue can be improved by implementing a special javascript event method to wait for the composition of the keywords input in
before the people triggering the search
to. In this clip
we can see some improvement.
We can find the English typing words normally, and the Japanese word for corona only queries the result when the word is completed.
In Drupal there are autonomous fields for tags or referencing entities.
The core has the issue before, but it was fixed in 2,016.
Thanks to the Drupal contributors.
Mainly, it is the composition event that helps us to identify the spatial event when the typing is finished.
When we create a custom auto-complete search box we have to implement the event. As well.
First we detect the starting point of the Cdk input method.
Next, we wait until the war is decided.
as we see the composition and event happened.
Finally, we send this Ajax request
after the typing issue. Let's see some sorting issue in English. We even saw with the alphabet of the title of articles.
taxonomy, tags, or nams. For example.
however.
it is entirely different when starting in Japanese, or even in Chinese.
In Japanese language most of us know it is
usually older with the
could you.
and also there are Kanji or Chinese characters, too.
when we have an array composed
of Latin letters, numbers Hiragana, Karagana
Kanji.
How do we saw them correctly
the idea order in Japanese language. She looks like these on the right.
starting with simple number alphabet like in English, and then Hiragana, Karagana, and the last part the Kanji.
Hiragana and Kalagana follows the order of gorgeon. But what is the order in Kanji?
If we use the sort function directly.
it will usually sort the array based on an indexed number of each correctors in the Unicode table.
However, this doesn't make sense for Japanese speakers, as the order of the correctors doesn't reflect the proper way to sort them in the language.
One solution is to use the javascript function locale. Compare this function source. Kanji, based on the pronunciation of the first correctors
and then the next correctors. If the first characters is the same
in Php, there is also a similar function to do the sorting, but it is recommended to use a database query for better sorting results from the back end.
However, this is not perfect yet. There is one word misplaced in the middle
you washed up.
it is because the Kanji has
another pronunciation.
The first characters is read in an alternative way, gone
rather than you are
to another example. There is another last name can be called either colonel or colonel. You see, in the same Kanji.
So in Japanese or in Mandarin Chinese the character could have more than one pronunciation.
How many characters has more than one pronunciation?
Japanese country has more than 600 out of 2,000 common correctors, with just more than one pronunciations.
an official definition from the Ministry of Education of Taiwan.
There were 1,200 out of 5,000 commonly used traditional Chinese characters
around. 10 years ago
officials reviewed, emerged, many of them reducing the number down to the
Let's take a look at the plan. For example.
it has more pronunciation due to different cultural contexts.
4 of them are inherited from the ancient Chinese in various era.
Another 4 represents the original terminus language.
The original Chinese character looks very similar.
and he has 3 pronunciations.
The character stands for you for music or love for happy or happiness, or yell for the verb to appreciate.
So we
now no Japanese soared by pronunciation. How about many Chinese?
Let's bring some delicious how in his food Here
they are in the order.
My preference
How do we solve the names using their attribute?
Let's first see what options do we have.
This is the first characters of Iwakuni
Y. In Mandarin.
There are at least 4 different ways to sort it.
We can count its radical strokes.
total strokes.
spell it with Fernando
element, 2 in
which is only using Tau one or opinion with Roman correctors, which is the main input method in China.
Usually we order with one of the attributes.
Sometimes let the user change the sorting method. For instance, the book search system in a library
in traditional Chinese locale compared function also works with the various attributes that I mentioned before
by strokes
or by the phonetic doing.
This is sorting with the phonetic element in a similar way that we saw Japanese ingredients.
It would be difficult to understand if you don't understand doing.
But the I it may be easier.
This is sorting in the total strokes
we can see the first characters of each
has more strokes from left and right.
It's amazing that Javascript is supported right.
It is all. Thanks to the open source contributors, especially in the Unihan project.
a sub branch
project under the unical Open Source project
that makes this available.
Let's think about the unresolved issue, what to do with the multiple pronunciation in Kanji.
the issue of facts, Japanese Kanji, or a Chinese characters when sorting with the phonetic elements doing or opinion.
Technically, native speakers know the common variations of the pronunciation.
When we process inhab it, process together.
It doesn't really bother the native speakers when the
different pronunciation mixed together.
However, my understanding could be wrong about Japanese.
I would be happy to hear from you what is the particle solution here
Sometimes, if the clients request to make it in a explicit order.
the better way is to map the word into a predefined table or array
at the end. I want to share a sentence with you.
We hear people say
devil is in the details.
It means the difficulty or troubles is not revealed until you look close to the details.
The origin of the sentence is somehow upset.
Kamiya.
It is from Germany
architecture.
Their lips got stacked in their tile.
No matter. It is devil or God.
The sentence has one thing in common.
The most important things are in the details.
When we see a new website is complete people cheering and feel satisfied
when the visitor find the good experience using the website in their native town. Intuitively
it is all because the developer designer walk on every detail to bring the best ux
to our users.
Let's look closer and take the challenge.
Deal with the devil.
We will find a glorious miracle in the end.
Thank you. I'm. Chris. I wish you a good afternoon today in the following sessions.
ご清聴ありがとうございました